[Music]
valued at over a hundred million dollars
fifty million it's really significant
for me because it was my first movie
after having my son but I walked on this
out and like you know my weights a
little up and I'm just I'm just aware of
it and hathaway telling Ellen DeGeneres
how her ocean's 8 co-star has helped her
overcome her post-baby body insecurities
and I walk on the set and like I'm in my
jeans and I've done my best and I'm
gonna love myself in the matter what and
Sandy Bullock just looks up and goes
looking good mama
made me feel amazing and then Cate
Blanchett's like nice jeans out the way
it's so great but it seems Rihanna had
the biggest impact of all and then
Rihanna looks up and goes damn girl you
gotta ask and I of course was freaked
out and loved it so much and I was like
really and she goes you gotta ask like
me no secret an is a huge fan of her
Barbadian co-star Rihanna last year she
gushed to et about working with the
superstar you don't realize it how often
you sing Rihanna songs just like under
your breath Wow you know they just like
and that happened to me a couple times
where I started a song and just kind of
had to cut it off really fast because it
was so inappropriate he's ubiquitous and
I'm fabulous
you